it's
still dry january emilia and i have been
doing dry january
and i think
she's breaking right january right now
what is this i'm making a cocktail oh oh
you don't say
busted ashton kutcher catches wife mila
kunis breaking a promise and exposes it
for the world to see no comment
yeah it all went down on instagram
apparently the couple agreed to go stone
cold sober for the first month of the
year but mila pulled out of the deal a
day early here's her reasoning um maybe
yeah it's still dry january nope yeah no
it's you know i work off of the lunar
calendar
so it's wet february for me right now
don't worry about it so not sure what
february is a thing but we'll let you
have that one mila thank you
now it's rare we get a glimpse into mila
and ashton's super private world but
when they do let us in it's always a
treat what's going on it's over between
us it's over between us that was the
couple joking around about tabloid
rumors back in 2019 fast forward to 2021
and ashton entertain us all by quizzing
mila on tech terms
hey babe yeah
what's uh crypto
it's digital currency
then came the great bath debate
i washed my armpits and my crotch daily
and nothing else ever the internet had a
collective meltdown about personal
hygiene practices after milan ashton
revealed they don't exactly bathe their
kids seven-year-old wyatt and
five-year-old dimitri that often if you
can see the dirt on them clean them yeah
otherwise there's no point which led to
this instagram gem you're putting water
on the children yeah are you trying to
melt them
are you trying to injure them with water
this is ridiculous what's going on
we're bathing that's like the fourth
time this week four times this week
too much
that's great your body oils are gonna be
destroyed
what are you trying to do
and after they had their fun with the
faux controversy mila told et she was
done discussing the ordeal in the bath
debate
i mean
i refused to i'm now literally gonna be
like no comment
were you surprised by the reaction how
many people weighed in like cardi b
weighed in the rock weighed in i don't
think i'm aware of how many people
weighed in i was in a different country
when in this when this
storm hit bleep it out if you must i
know i know you can um uh but i um it
didn't i didn't i don't think that i was
aware
honestly of what was happening with
but it's great listen if it gets
people's mind off of reality who cares
and we thank you for that mila honestly
these two are pretty much couple goals
always keeping it real every night that
we put wyatt down we high five each
other and we're like we did it
every single day we kept her alive we're
like she's alive
and we're still in love like it's a you
high-five when you still like each other
and you still like your kid at the end
of the night because sometimes they're
the devil